hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm so they're gonna be
going over a game from round two of the
2014 candidates tournament our players
White's gonna be commanded by Peters
fiddler and then blacks gonna be played
by Dmitry and Rican again two really
really talented players white decides to
start with Pawnee for pawn c5 so we do
have the Sicilian defense which is one
of the more common openings that we'll
see Knight f3 knight c6 pond d4 captures
very common from both sides pawn to e5
is a little bit new it's pretty common
to see pawn to d6 early on maybe later
pushing forward the pond to e5 so
definitely not the most common opening
night to b5 pawn to d6 this does have a
backwards pawn here on d6 very very
common for black it can be a weakness
later on if he's not careful but but
early on it's just not a big deal for
black because he has so many ways to
defend this but something to keep an eye
on then pawn to a c4 now this is
interesting because way more common
White's gonna play Bishop to c4 both
these pawns on d6 and e5 are kind of
locked in so this kind of frees up this
long light square diagonal for this
Bishop you obviously want to have both
your minor pieces involved into the game
castle on one side of the board the
bishop can even come back here to b3
have a lot of havoc over here on the
King side from black knowing good and
well that he's probably not gonna be
cancelling on the Queen side just
because he's given up his C pawn due to
the Sicilian defense but in the
particular game
we have pawn here to c4 and we are kind
of off to the races both sides are going
to continue to develop black plays
Bishop to e7
we have Knight to c3 pawn to a6 I really
like this waiting move from black
playing the bishop here to d7 before he
forces this night away now that the
Knights on c3 this forces this Knight to
come back here to a3 very awkwardly
placed knight by white here so a great
move from black white really needs to
now find a way to get this tonight
involved to the action because right now
it's not doing a whole heck of a lot
Bishop here to East 6 centralizing also
developing all of his pieces we have
Bishop here at d2 getting ready to
castle on the King side and then Bishop
here to g5 now black has a few options
in this particular case you can always
play Knight to d4 does have a nice
little outpost here he could always
bring his rook over here to see a
doesn't have a semi-open file rooks do
extremely well and send me open files
he couldn't even just continue with his
development Knight here to f6 castle on
King side in this particular defense
though a lot of times players will try
to play bishop here to g5 exchange off
these dark square bishop then bring
their Queen down here to g5 and try to
launch an attack that's exactly what
black decided to do in this particular
game good for white though is he
actually played this pretty smart in
this exchange and he didn't take right
away and said he played Knight to see to
and then after the exchange the rook
takes on c1 and now the Queen comes down
here to g5 and think about this how
different it is instead of the bishop
taking on a g5 and the Queen taking on
g5 all of a sudden white does not have
his Knights on c2 does not have his rook
over here on c1 all of a sudden white is
kind of down in the moves but because he
kind of waited they should always do
this in your own games even if you want
to exchange but white could sit here and
say I definitely want to give up my dark
square bishop that doesn't mean you
should go ahead and take it right away
see if you can get a few extra moves
especially if you know your opponent
wants to exchange and then get his Queen
involved into the game and that's
exactly what Peter Svidler did he played
Knight here to c2 and then after the
exchange he has a few extra moves on the
board and I decides to go ahead and
castle on the Kings side doesn't want to
have King side safety and now that works
gonna swing over here to these we talked
about Black has this backward pawn here
on d6 he has to be worried about the
bishop the dark squared bishop was kind
of holding on to it and his queen was
kind of holding on to it now that both
of those are no longer holding on to it
definitely needs to make sure that he is
protecting it and so he brings his rook
over here to d8
next move from white does have a lot of
options play pawn here to b4 knows
opponent dmitri after the game said he
really didn't like this move later on
spinner would go on to criticize some of
the
trees moves as well which we'll talk
about later in the game but if I kind of
look at the board this is not a bad move
for white at all I actually think this
is it's pretty good I think it's doing
exactly what he needs to do putting a
lot of pressure on this Queen side so I
don't really know where he wanted him to
go maybe Knight to d5 right away and
just not mess with it potentially play
pawn here to b3 if you wanted to maybe
have a stronger pawn chain but b4 is
still pretty strong there's no great
attack that black can really do here and
now we have Knight to f6 again
definitely want to make sure that there
is a castle on the King side don't want
to leave your King exposed too much then
we have Queen here to d3 and we have
castling on the King side the rooks are
going to swing you over here to the one
putting more pressure on this pawn on d6
black decides to go ahead and swing his
rook over he recognizes there's too much
pressure on here so he's gonna just
swing his rook over here to c8 not too
worried about it
now the Knights gonna swing in here to a
d5 this is another one of those moves
that Dimitra kind of looked at and said
yeah not too sure if this is the best
move out there but all in all you know
again I think it was pretty good black
now played a pawn to b5 and Spindler
said this is one of the worse
moves that black could have played in
this position instead he likes the rook
swinging over here to the 8th now that
it's kind of clogged up getting his
other brooken bombs of the game
protecting again this backwards pawns
here on d6 makes a little bit more sense
but in the game again we have pawn here
to b5 and then the Queen's gonna swing
over here to g3 now I really thought
that we were gonna see the knight take
here on f6 and then after we have a take
here then play would continue but
instead we see a nice little move from
Peters Finland he plays Queen here to g3
and then after the Queen takes the
knight now takes and only now takes on
f6 because it forces his opponent to
have doubled pawns here and also has an
opening for white to attack and so we
see the double pawns right here and then
White's going to
take back here this is a little bit
better for white he doesn't have a
isolated pawn like black des over here
again he does have doubled pawns but
again they're all sort of connected this
is definitely going to be an easier in
game for white to play especially since
there's these rooks they could easily
get over here it's gonna be very
difficult for black to hold on to it if
he doesn't play correctly now Black's
going to take with his pawn here on c4
and then in my opinion one of the best
moves in the game you can see there's a
lot of tension on this pawn on c4 but
white plays pawn here to f4 what's
interesting about this is it may go
unnoticed if you're just going through
the game but it's these type of moves
the incrementally gets you an advantage
in a game if we look at this position
right here again black has taken
material here on c4 and all of a sudden
white needs to figure out what he wants
to do he could take here on these six
again he just gave up material so it
could take with his rook but then after
the rook comes to d8 all of a sudden
there's an exchange black controls this
long file right here he does have some
pretty active pieces he has a nice
little outpost he can come to with his
knight it's not really clear how White's
gonna have the advantage this is pretty
much equal in my opinion if we look at
both sides of the board instead he
recognizes that he's down a pawn the
material after that exchange but instead
of just trying to figure out how he can
take this right away he pushes forward
with pawn to f4 he recognizes that he
can next play pawn to f5 forcing this
bishop away that will open up the door
for the bishop or the pawn here on c4 to
be taken but if the pawn takes on f4
then Y can respond by taking back white
no longer has doubled pawns black on
that only has doubled pawns but they're
now isolated and he has no protection
from pawns on either side of the board
so all in all this is gonna be very very
good for Peter Svidler Dmitri decides to
go ahead and defend with pawn to f5 this
is gonna be completely okay for white
he's now going to take and now after the
bishop takes the Knights now gonna swing
over here to either
very very nice square and that only
attacking the bishop but also attacking
the pawn here on c4 black still has a
pretty fighting chance in this game he
has to play correct instead of playing
correct that we plays one of the worst
moves he could have and he plays Bishop
here to d3 giving up some one of the
advantage that he potentially may have
had we could have continued with Bishop
to c4 and then after the Knight takes
again taking that material back on the
board then we see another Knight take
now the knight can take here on d6 and
if we look at it black still has a
fairly good game we could see the rook
come back here to c5 attacking material
why it's gonna be able to stabilize on
the material and then all of a sudden he
should have a pretty good in game since
his opponent does have this these
isolated pawns over here although this
one is a passed pawn on a6 white still
probably has the advantage if we come
back in the game though instead of
playing bishop there to e4 black decided
to play bishop here to d3 and Peter's
fella saw this and quickly took
advantage he played bishop takes on d3
after the pawn takes on d3 the Knight to
f5 and this move right here is just a
dagger in the position it really shows
how poorly constructed black's pieces
are set up towards the end of the game
and now it's just a matter of execution
getting his pieces exactly where they
need to be for the final blow so there's
no real great square that black can go
to he does decide to push forward with
pawn to e4 one last attempt to kind of
push forward with his pawns white now
responds with taking here on d6
attacking the rook here on c8 again
black decides to push forward with this
pawn here on e3 pretty much giving up
this rook here on CA now if we kind of
look at different options if black
decided to instead play rook here to c7
again that's still not going to be that
great we can now have just the knight
take here on e4 if we want to
wife's just gonna continue to gobble up
material he's gonna be up too many pawns
in this game for black to really do too
much on the board if black decides to
play rook anywhere else let's say rook
here to be eights then Y can go ahead
and just come in swoop in take this
night here on c6 and again blacks just
gonna be down too much material so he
didn't like any of those options which
makes sense none of them are really good
he plays pawn here to e4 saying hey I'm
gonna give up material he continues to
push forward with III I'm gonna give up
material and I'm just gonna continue to
push forward and hopefully I can come up
with something plays to the rook at
taking hit the night here on c6 and then
we see pawn here to e2 again a
phenomenal move from white here he plays
rook to c1 again one of these ponds is
going to promote but really can't do too
much we now see the pawn take here the
rooks gonna capture again it really
didn't matter if he turned it into a
real core a queen it was gonna be
captured right away decided to turn into
a rook after captures this pawn can't
really go anywhere the rook can capture
this knight but now all of a sudden we
see white is up two pawns and material
going into the endgame there's just no
way for black to overcome that and so in
this particular case Dmitry decided to
go ahead and resign so great game by
Peters findly again exceptionally great
to see him playing at such a high level
especially in round two any time you're
playing with the white pieces you want
to come out with a draw or specifically
a win if you can get a win under your
belt that's early on this gives you a
lot of confidence go into the late
around so hopefully you guys enjoyed
this game shows you some of the little
subtleties in chests that actually end
up giving you wins at this high level
format I'll be again doing commentary
for each round I'll be picking a game
that I think you guys will enjoy if you
haven't already there'll be a link in
the description for the new Facebook
page make sure you check that out and
like it you can also make sure that you
get notifications we are always posting
content to that so make sure there's a
button next to the like button make sure
that you have
check that see you guys in the next
video thanks for watching see you next
time